foreign
how can we help
thanks for taking my call you bet what's
going on Sarah awesome my husband and I
are on baby step three and cannot get
out uh wondering if husband should stay
home to get really radical with the baby
steps to just start stacking cash and
Propel us for it whoa wow
a two-year-old and a five-year-old okay
and and and and how would he staying at
home allow you guys to make progress
explain the numbers
absolutely so Child Care here in the
Chicago area for three kids is four
thousand six hundred dollars okay a
month holy smokes um yes for two kids
because my oldest is going to public
school in August for two kids because of
their ages and also
um every year they increase tuition
which is always expected it goes to 3
700 a month so there's only a 900
savings
um we make 260
000 as a household I make a hundred and
seventy thousand and my husband makes
ninety thousand so when you look at the
take home I take home after taxes and
health insurance which is on mine my
take home
um would be 8 300. and my husband's take
home with taxes because we're dual
income family is four thousand eight
hundred so he's pretty much paying the
daycare bills and we just have no margin
if something comes up
um whatever it might be we've built up
baby step three so many times we've been
almost done it two years we paid off a
hundred and five thousand dollars in
debt in 14 months with one kid we got
after it big time we cashed out stocks
sold a car like got rid of leases we
went really at it
um but we just can't Propel Ford because
you know we had more kids we've moved
we've propelled our careers but we can't
get ahead so we're looking for something
to unlock us well will the margin but
will the margin be there yes I
understand that the expense goes away
but you're still at the you're still at
the same 8300
yeah no it's a great point so looking at
um the every dollar app which we love
and we've been through FPU with my take
home of 8 300.
um it gives us still left to budget
after doing house and insurance because
all our health insurance Etc it would
give us about two thousand two hundred
dollars less to budget so we would try
to
um maneuver that to be I'm confused
though because his take-home pay is
still more than you're paying for
daycare so how do you end up with more
money if he stays home
um well I think we also look at cutting
different
um budgets and different things just to
get to get radical because we also have
to pay for
um sorry after school care as well so
why not oh you're saying there's other
expenses
I still think you're gonna net I mean
I'm looking at the numbers here you're
paying 44 in take-home pay towards
daycare he's making 57 and take home pay
oh no he's making 4 800 and take-home
pay I understand 57 000 a year is what
he's bringing home and you're paying in
daycare 44 000 a year if it goes down to
3 700 a month
right but that's 900 George just you you
shared but there's 900 right there
right okay I think that's what well too
like we've been trying like cash flow is
very challenging for us we've been
trying we've been trying to like get
ahead it just seems like something
always kind of comes up I think there's
other expenses your daycare is
astronomical don't get me wrong yeah but
you guys are taking home
over thirteen thousand dollars a month
we are so where is the other nine
thousand dollars going
yes I'm looking at the
um the house is 4 500 because our rent's
2400 and then to keep the house
operating is about four thousand five
hundred
um we have gas I'm in sales so I travel
for work
um and then I mean we've had to
um you know I think our discretion got a
little out of hand so we carried that
back
we've had some travel we had a parent
death
um in the family we've had two babies
we've had a ton of medical
um just because we were paying off debt
we didn't go in stroke mode so we're
just behind we're trying to figure out
the debt is gone life has hit you but
now we're looking ahead and we're going
all right the debt is gone life's not
always going to be this chaotic we're
not always going to be in daycare but
just look at the numbers the first place
I would cut is not his entire income the
first place I'd cut is everything else
in the budget including the
discretionary spending I I have a
suggestion Sarah that I want you to be
open-minded to okay yeah
okay great and this is from our
experience from Stacy and I's experience
when the kids were younger my kids are
teenagers now but when they were younger
I was here at Ramsey
and Stacy was working full-time and we
needed someone to be there so they were
in school but we needed someone to be
there when they got home from school
around 2 30 until around 5 36 so that
the kids were doing their homework and
and then you know so we we looked at
that and we found a nice lady we look
for a lot for I don't know I'd say a
long time say four or five months we
found the right person
and it was a retired lady she's a
grandmother and so she was a fraction of
what it was going to cost us to use a
service
and I would just consider that if I were
you if your husband kept his income and
let's say uh because you're already
going to pay for after school care
anyway
so what if for the two Littles that are
not going to be in school in the fall
you find a grandmother somebody that you
met through a church or a neighbor
somebody in there did you check them all
in care.com and find a part-time Nanny
yeah but just what if we did that and
they were in your home they were being
cared for the person did laundry you
know they help with meal planning major
what's that I said preach yeah that
would be amazing but but but you have to
look into that this is not like
something that I've just crafted in in
my head right this is possible and so
let's just say that that person George
do some math for me if you pay them an
hourly rate of 15 20 an hour I don't
know what that would be but depending on
only 20 for Chicago area I imagine 20 to
25 because we did look at nannies that
may not work out it may not work out but
the point is is if you figure out a way
some of the hours you just gotta find a
way I don't think him coming home is the
right move here this is something he
wants okay
he's open to it we just are trying to
get ahead I think we need to be working
more not less yeah I think he actually
needs to work too I think you but I
think he needs to work a second job
maybe for three months six months a year
truthfully the house payment if you if
it's just your income the house is just
too much at that point
so if you lose this income the numbers
get skewed in a bad way and so I would
keep the income and I'd find every other
place to cut because it sounds like
truthfully there's probably some other
things we could cut first and this just
feels like a nice shortcut to hopefully
fix things but My worry is he stays home
nothing is fixed it's still chaotic
because the numbers didn't really change
right right
um no that's fair thank you we're just
looking at all sorts of options so you
guys were my first phone call
listen go find your Mrs Doubtfire I
think that's the play I really do I
really appreciate it I think the
number's going to be in your favor but
run the numbers crunch the numbers based
on your market and we'll see George but
I I like that move they're not in the
daycare system they're in their home
that person can also do some things
around the house you heard how she was
like oh that'd be nice yeah imagine if
they're doing laundry helping with meal
planning the daycare struggle is real it
is especially in these you don't get any
of those home benefits they don't do
your laundry they're not doing meal
planning that'd be nice they're just
chalking your kids full of gummies and
what do you call those goldfish those
cheddar cheese snacks that you love so
much